time now for a special Black Friday
Edition of CBS mornings deals where we
share items with you all at exclusive
discounts to start shopping now scan the
QR code that you see on your screen
right there or you can visit
cbsdeals.com lifestyle host Gail bass is
here with us now good morning Happy
Thanksgiving good morning happy Black
Friday everybody you don't have to put
on your clothes to go shop at
cbsdeals.com stay in your PJs and hey if
you're working on your computer or your
laptop it doesn't have to be on your
laptop let's talk about that let's talk
about this easy best this is one of our
exclusive Black Friday deals because
people love this this sold out last time
this is a laptop this is a universal
laptop stand that you could use to raise
the computer up if you've been sitting
all day and you want to stand up and
work Tony has one and you just use this
how do you do it oh yeah you don't want
to do that right now because you have to
you push in the size and you oh I see
and you raise it up and down to where
it's particular for you here is how it
will look to you if you look at this
screen right here if you look at it here
you can see that this for your mouse is
reversible on both sides what I love
about this deal is um you could get it
for 21 wow 50 off it's a great price
remember this is our Black Friday place
I love it and it sold out last time so
you want to get this sold out last time
I did so you want to get this one I'm
gonna get I actually want one of these
okay let me see you after well let me
see okay catch a girl outside catch me
just catch me in the next room or at
cbsdeals.com all right let's talk
glasses because I just actually it's
funny I just broke my reading glasses me
too did you really I did I broke my I
broke the uh I broke one of the arms off
two of them okay and this is one where
you want to stock up on these here let
me just use these readers okay to see
what this deal is let's say we got Black
Friday AJ Morgan's these are blue light
blocking which we all need because we
use so many computers laptops tablets
and our phones so these have blue light
blocking in them and they are also
affordable and they're fun look at these
These are vintage inspired oh yeah let's
see here yeah here we go we can put ours
on yeah very cool thank you I like it
they look good right they do look good
actually what's great is I can actually
these are really these are perfect I
might just wear these while we finish
this out you know we'll just gift those
to you because it is the holiday season
and this is our Black Friday deal I love
it and we've got these at CBS deals for
Fort starting at 14 what I love is they
come with these little bags you could
just wipe them off they get a little
Schmutz on them 14 bucks yeah yeah it's
starting at 14. that is awesome I love
that so that's something else I'm
picking up and finally Gail I've been so
excited to see this like massager I was
we teased it last night or yesterday
morning and I've been waiting I was
talking about it this morning yes so
what goes on here what's happening this
is the air sea heat and people I know
who are athletes and people like myself
helpful hike a lot I love these These
are great for Recovery what's really
good about the air sea heat here is that
it has knee warming along with
compression so this will help with your
recovery it massages the leg it's a
compressor so if you are if you're an
athlete or you go to the gym or a lot or
you work out a lot or you've been
sitting at your desk all day or standing
on your feet all day this is the perfect
gift for that person in your life
because think about it if you go to a
massage parlor or you go you get
somebody to come into your home that's
going to cost you close to two hundred
dollars in the price here the price here
is 119. one the price of one visit to a
massage therapist is what you're going
to pay for this and you can do this with
your convenience and it has a bag that
comes with it so you can take it with
you I I mean this is so literally
everything today I mean working on my
laptop right need to see what's on the
screen yes I grab my glasses let me see
what this is yep 40 off 119 for the air
sea heat I love all the stuff from Marie
athlete all my friends I come over and
use it I'm like leg massage
I love it love it love it uh Gail bass
thank you very much love having you on
WE partner with all of these companies
to get these deals to buy anything that
you saw today like these peepers scan
that QR code on your screen or head over
to cbsdeals.com to start shopping now
your local news coming up next